tard non je suis arrivé on trouve
également liberté d'expression donc
c'est vous et souhaite jeunes qui est le
numéro un du rock chinois
celui qui en 1989 au moment du mouvement
étudiant avait chanté sur la place
tiananmen avec un bandeau rouge sur les
yeux alors dans le dvd on voit répéter
la chanson de piaf la foule dans un
studio et ensuite on vous voit lui
expliquer que vous n'êtes pas sûr de
pouvoir le faire monter sur scène
effectivement il ya eu un veto des
autorités chinoises
mais mais ça c'est dit nulle part comme
la demande dvd quand quand on m'a
proposé ce de faire l'ouverture de la
france en chine au coeur de pékin avant
d'accepter
j'ai rencontré quand même un certain
nombre de deux d'amis écrivains
musiciens ou artistes ou intellectuels
chinois pour savoir si c'était
finalement bien par rapport à la vision
qu'ont à nous de la chine
et pas seulement la vision qu'on a mais
la réalité c'est à dire qu'un pays qui
n'est quand même pas complètement
raccord et politiquement correct aux
plantes droits de l'homme savoir si
c'est une bonne idée de faire et j'étais
étonné de voir que 100% des des artistes
chinois ont dit il faut il faut
absolument qu'ils le fassent d'abord
dont on ne connaît en chine ensuite ce
n'est pas un chinois qui va le faire et
pour nous c'est une opportunité de
pouvoir reprendre la main sur le plan
culturel sur le plan intellectuel au
centre de la capitale et donc la
responsabilité moi qu'est la condition
je me suis mise à moi même c'était
d'intégrer et de vraiment de l'essayer
de d'appliquer les musiciens dissidents
les peintres les vidéastes au maximum
dans ce concert passe sous forme de
festival est vraiment d appliquer dans
le projet et ça ça a été finalement
assez réussi on a effectivement négocié
pied à pied jusqu'au bout et que sur le
sont les trois musiciens effectivement
qui était avec moi sur scène qu'ils
étaient tous les trois très impliquée
dans les évènements 89 un seul n'a pas
pu n'a pas pu être là et ils nous ont
expliqué hier on en est finalement gelée
gelé
reconnue c'est que il ya une différence
pour aller faire des concerts comme sap
comme ça et puis et puis de faire un
concert dans un cadre extrêmement
formelle avec devant les membres du
gouvernement qui seront pris la
télévision en direct en train de nous
dire c'est donc c'était donc finalement
on a on est tombé d'accord qu'il serait
sur dvd qui serait sur la retransmission
internet mais que deux autres musiciens
notamment la fille qu'on vient de voir
jouer qui est qui était une des grandes
chanteuses et les joueuses de deux héros
chinois qui a été la femme du leader
étudiant 89 soit là donc je pense que je
pense que c'est bien aussi de comprendre
aussi le fait que bon bah finalement sur
trois il ya deux qui étaient là et puis
évidemment bon le fait de dire liberté
égalité fraternité en chinois en direct
à la télévision était finalement un pari
réussi et les objectifs que je m'étais
fixé et qu'on s'était fixés je pensais
peut-être parfaitement réussi et je
crois que ça ça pose la question de
savoir est ce qu'il faut aller dans un
pays comme la chine
est ce qu'il faut aller s'exprimer ce
qu'il faut les jouer ce qu'il faut aller
montrer ses films est ce qu'il faut
aller
la réponse à mon avis est évidemment oui
puisque vous êtes j'allais mais reporter
sans frontières étaient opposés à ça et
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs oui je trouve
que c'est une erreur
je pense que il faut arrêter d'avoir ces
espèces de d'arrogance souvent au boycot
ce move qui fait que au bout du compte
en ce qui concerne les chinois les
chinois comme ces fiches un peu de
l'opinion de la france et je crois que
c'est pas une solution je crois qu'il
faut il faut être astucieux il faut
venir à l'intérieur de l'armement en
prévente est là vous y allé et puis
qu'est ce qui est à signaler quand même
c'est que là c'est la première fois que
les visions chinoise a retransmis un
concert en direct sans coupure c'est que
j'aurais très bien pu me couper aussi
quand quand j'ai fait liberté de
fraternité en chinois sur le pass
tiananmen c'est vrai qu'ils auraient
tout à fait plus d'un le coupé ils n'ont
pas fait
isabelle adjani bon on va pas revenir là
dessus c'est plein de votre attitude
jean-michel voilà on a déjà parlé il ya
quelqu'un d'autre qui récemment ici
c'est plein de votre attitude c'est jean
pierre raffarin
non
samatha libyen lors à chaque fois un
point oui et si on essayait de placer le
plus souvent venue de jean-pierre
raffarin
c'est ça c'est le but du jeu tu marques
un point chaque fois mais faut il
vraiment fédérer vont le faire
habilement il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui
récemment ici c'est plein de votre
attitude c'est patrick juvet qui s'est
plaint que vous l'avez laissé tombé en
mer d'après une histoire d'amour et dim
a laissé tomber et et ses malheurs
apparemment viennent de là s'il est dans
cet état là patrick juvet aujourd'hui je
savais pas moi vous allez vous avez
abandonné juste rabat je suis très trop
vite quand une valise à la cantine
fautes et les téléphones qu'est ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sérieusement vous étiez très proche à un
moment est proche et qu'elle soit que ce
soit patrick juvet ou christophe vous
d'autres effectivement je les travaille
avec hubble à travailler ensemble et
deux albums on est on a toujours été
très bons amis évidemment il y mettait
une dimension on aurait dû s'assurer de
filles voire amoureuse que vous n'étiez
s'extérioriser plus on va s'arrêter de
changer mon destin mais en tout cas ça
n'a pas été le cas lille comme un peu un
bourreau des coeurs quand même un bon je
pars avec 6 am on s'est régalé comme je
l'aï déjà des maîtresses de m